[Music]
hello everybody welcome to
my residency
so i'm going to be your grandmaster in
residence for the next two weeks so
you're gonna have a lot of fun with me
on youtube on twitch
if you're here in person
so thank you for being here everybody i
see a few faces it's too bright so i
can't see everybody
um but
so for today i was just going through
you know since it's called like the
grandmaster's choice i was just looking
through some of the favorite
um books that i have or favorite like
chapters i've read and there's this one
book that i recommended to one of my
students recently brian or chess bonzo
and it was like a um it's chess secrets
and there's like a dynamic there's like
a giants of power play there's a giants
of strategy i like both of them
and
it's very well explained it has a lot of
commentary it has very
it's just so well thought out
and i really like it so
um when i first started teaching because
i was still trying to find my style i
kind of went back and forth between
those books a lot
uh but
now i was going to look into
i really like this because you know and
whenever i'm working with my students
i'm talking about how importance peace
activity is how importance having that
dynamic element is and there's a little
there's literally a chapter called
dynamic elements so
there we go
or something about king in the center so
my goal for tonight would be to try and
get
two games and one from to show you the
dynamic element and one to show you you
know how to punish the opponents when
they leave their king in the center
so
keeping that in mind uh let's go ahead
and jump in the name of the players
would also be embedded in the leachate
study and for the first game alejand is
going to be white
let me double check the year yep 1943.
so
uh please feel free to jump in the chats
and also feel free to
um
say stuff in person oh before i forget i
mean i forgot the most important news so
um for those of you who have been
following my journey to get into which
med school where am i gonna go where
i'll be in two months i finally know so
i'm officially in slough no i wish to
graduating from slu
but i'm going to mizzou we'll figure out
the chess team stuff later
if slash win
but i'm officially going to be a med
student there i put on the deposit i'm
looking for moving stuff so if you guys
wanna
i don't know
say congratulations or come up with a
drink or something that'll be cool
all right uh
yes
i'm ready to jump in ready to jump in
all right cool
so dynamic element let's see how
alekhine teaches his opponents fair
warning i've
i've always played either grand prix or
the real stuff i've played smithmore a
little bit so i've never really played
alpine so
just
just know that this is not my expertise
in the opening however i have a feeling
the opening might have changed a little
in the last i don't know 60 50 70 years
so
this is 1943.
uh quick question does anybody here or
there play alopen as white as black
i see some
okay nobody
before
that's fair
all right well that's totally cool
um
it doesn't have to be a very
it's it's sharp
but this is something i was also talking
to in my camp kits
the previous hour
we were talking about um you know how
important it is to know your openings
even if you play a weird gambit you
gotta know it you have to know what
you're doing in the opening so for those
of you who don't
don't leave just yet make sure to finish
watching the stream then go ahead and
review your openings or create a nice
opening repertoire something that goes
with your style or something that you
find comfort in but you need to know it
you need to know the pawn structure
which side you're going to castle how
you're going to do stuff in center which
we're going to actually see in this
opening a little bit too now quick
question
um white has a decent center right but
if take and take
take
we are going to have a bunch of stuff
happening in the center right isolated
pawn for example
so let's talk about that for a minute
anything um
anything that would worry you
and since it's probably gonna be
isolated pawns how do you think black
should set up how do you think white
should set up
let's start with do you think anybody
will be castling alongside
i agree i don't think anybody is going
to be dreaming about long castle
so
probably there's going to be a bunch of
fights against this pawn right see they
can try to attack it this way we're
going to be trying to defend it this way
there's going to be a bunch of attacks
and defenses the what are the big things
that we know about isolated pawns
especially isolated the the queen gambit
style isolated pawn
true
so give me some of the strengths
wait i don't know who said what can't
see anything
true
but
so what would be some of the strengths
controlling c5 and d5 true have so it
means having open c files if this has
happened
so this would be open c file
so
because let me ask you this
having isolated pawn
would you like to go to an endgame
most likely no i agree so it means you
want to keep more of your pieces it
means you want to create more attacks
right
so when you want to create more attacks
then you should also be working on
potential
king side attacks right so this would be
a very expensive diagonal for you
so this is already giving you some ideas
you know you want a short castle you
wish you could do this and opponent also
knows what you want to do so they are
attacking here so you can't easily play
on d3 they are piling up against your
knight so again you can't easily play
bishop d3 and you're kind of forced into
playing bishop e2 i want to say forced
into but
kind of forced into honestly
because if you don't play it what are
you going to do with this bishop go
bishop d3 well that kind of feels a
little blundery so
yeah
so bishop e2 they take we take
and e6 was played logical right what do
you think is a good move for whites
right now
yeah i
agree and what do you think is a good
idea for black should they move this
queen or can they develop
i agree
now again they're pinning us but i don't
think it's a serious pin because if they
take we'll just take back and i've
always found more comfort in having
these like hanging pawns that i can push
around rather than an isolated pawn i'm
not opposed to isolated ponds but i've
always had more fun with hanging ponds
personally so i would love for them to
take me so what do you think is a good
idea now
could be but the main thing is that we
have isolated pond we we're right about
the castle they still need to get the
knight out and castle so we would want
to continue our little punches
i feel like a kangaroo right now but
um
we want to continue poking them we want
to continue our kicking and fighting and
biting and all those funny dynamic stuff
so we want a castle because now i'm
attacking now either you have to take or
you have to move the queen if you move
the queen
then i mean i'm kind of happy because
first things first
well your queen is no longer blocking my
pawn
second thing you still need to move this
knight and finally
if you don't move it if you take it then
i get my eyes on my hanging pawns and i
could start here i could start attacking
here
and you gain the momentum and i would
that would be very great
so in the game black went queen a5 what
do you think is a good idea for white
again keep in mind black if you give
black a one move or two they are gonna
do this so what do you think we should
do now
and keep in mind
king is in the center so
and also keep in mind this is kind of
called the the topic of the conversation
is dynamic elements so we want to be
gaining temples we want to be attacking
you already have like a mini hint
i like that but you can attack something
a little more
tasty
i like that
what if they take you
true but uh kind of also on like a
different
whoa whoa
no
no
where's the rest of my game
uh oh
technology
ouch
hold on
i know there's this game is somewhere
i'm so sorry this game was here
and i know in the game it was not taken
my apologies i'm gonna need a second to
figure out where is my game
because i remember
white ends up taking black takes here
it's kind of a weird stuff
uh
oh
nope that was not it
no
are you sure
uh it's not that alejand's game i mean
knight f6 looks about right and i
remember there was a take and there was
a take and i remember this game but i
don't know where it
has a knight is six to five
before he's taking down i remember there
is a stake but
okay
can you give that game to me
since lyches is
not giving me my game how do you want it
anywhere i can load it on leeches
actually can you go to the study
unloaded
sorry
you gotta love technology right
my apologies everybody this is
sometimes leeches plays little tricks
with me
chesponzo you look like you know what to
do
so how's everybody's day going
nice how are you oh well this is
making my day really amazing right now
what is your study called dorset uh the
same dorsa inn
and it's the 40th game
oh man
i was so excited for this game i looked
it up and i was like this is a 28 move
game i can get through two of them
see you just should i just paste it here
yeah
if you can create a new chapter and then
paste the pg in there
yeah
that's there's no way this is gonna work
i wish it i really hope it does i want
my alohain's game
if not we can
well
thank you james
also um while we're doing that let me
just make sure that the next game the
next game is here then why is this one
playing
tricks on me
yeah the next one is here also spoiler
alert
man
oh um something kind of fun something to
keep in mind
tomorrow and i believe thursday i'm
going to be doing um the play the people
ah it's here we're safe thank you chez
bonzo slash ben simon
oh my god
thank you i i'm also surprised leeches
didn't have this game as their master
games
somebody better than alejand who else
would you call him master
all right um
yeah thank you yeah knight f6 you're
correct d5 was played and it makes sense
right because
okay let me let me get back to the style
let me get back in my head
um i was thinking about taking but it's
might be a little too early because if
you play d5 after then rook d8
right you have already sacrificed a
little bit and we would much rather not
have that sacrifice
so
you want to
you're not
i'm not saying you shouldn't sacrifice i
am saying that you should be ready when
you're sacrificing so you should be at
your peak so
pawn to d5 would be great right and the
idea is if take then we can take back
and now you are kind of stuck taking it
here right because let's say if queen
takes b4
question what would we do to this queen
right now
and thank everybody for
staying around while
we find alheim
also is it all fine or
just because in when i grew up i just
called it
and it was like the pronunciation we
used in farsi
but i think people call alohain
it's close
it's more like
the what now
sure
so what do you want to do with this
queen
did you try to kick it away by moving
i love it let's say rk4 clean goes d6
how are you going to continue poking
around
keep in mind dynamic elements we want to
continue attacking and gaining tempo
94 i think it's okay um i'm not opposed
to it especially because if jake would
just take back with the rook bishop has
to go to e6 because if take then their
queen is dropping right
and then a part of me wants to do this
but another part of me wants to just
develop i mean that's also development
you know what i like it i'll stay with
it
another idea is also take which is if
take then i can take this guy
so i'm attacking and this is a really
awesome rook lift i really do thoroughly
enjoy the stroke lift
so
a plant um sorry here black didn't take
on b4 they took on a1 all right now what
do we do
anything specific you would like to do
i'm sorry
you want to take this
um the the one thing that kind of
concerns me with this is what if they
take and then just castle i don't think
it's fast enough if they can castle then
there's kind of safe
what else
ideally we would want to take it but we
need to poke around a little bit more or
or try to trap this queen either way i
would be happy
oh patrick in the chat is talking about
queen b3 it is interesting i think queen
b3 is also definitely one of those cool
ideas but what if they just take it you
try to take back then they are trying to
attack you
and if they take you don't take back
what do you say like bishop e3 to try
and attack then they can take you you
take back and they already ate a little
bit too much material i would much
rather either trap their clean before
giving this much material or instead of
um trapping their queen try to just go
for their king
so queen b3 is okay but it's not the
best one
so what do you think is the best one
well why would you want to exchange
queens
because your sacrifice and your
attacking you would ideally want to
avoid
exchanging unnecessarily
queen c3
where
that means e2
that's possible but i don't think that's
fast enough what if i just take here
patrick in the chat i think you have the
right idea i kind of like b5 that's not
the move that alejand went for because
if i'm assuming if p5 take if you take
then they can go 97 and if take it's
still good but
uh that's not the one that alejan went
for alejand kind of tried to
in all of these lines rick you keep
saying this take so then move the knight
and try to get it somewhat supposed to
to bother this queen
i think that could be interesting but
there is a little bit more activity the
problem with i mean it one the problem
is take
and then if you take with the queen they
block it and even if you go knight to c2
their queen can try to run
instead of knight e1 well how about
knight to d2 you have the similar idea
you want to go around the tactic queen
if they take you take with check they
block
but now you're because if your knight
was on e1 then your bishop would be
under attack right
since your knight is on d2 your bishop
is not under attack so you're not
obligated to attack the queen and kind
of push it away now you can come up with
a cooler idea so what do you think is
that cooler idea
i like that what's better than
threatening checkmate
and black here kind of has to castle i
can't really think of a different way
start i mean maybe not g8
but i mean if you have to play nitrate
that's just too cool i i mean i would
love that
uh
opponent kind of has the castle after
castle now what
yes this is technically a hanging knight
but if they take it what if they just go
rook e8
so
that would be problematic
what else
we would love to be able to eat that
night because that would give our
material back
and if you think about it
um
we would be we would have exchanged a
we would have given up a rook for if we
managed to eat this night we would have
given up a rook for a bishop and the
night
and
sorry we would have given up a rook and
a pawn for a bishop and a knight which
is totally good
because it's about peace activity it's
not necessarily about oh rook is five
points pawn is one points knight and
bishop are six you can also think about
it that way but that's not the most
efficient way it really really depends
about the position
so
i like that queen will definitely go to
a6 because it's not just bye-bye queen
exchange
yeah
quite simple right
now let's say here opponents um
is trying to decide how to continue i'm
actually going to put you in that shoes
black to move what do you want to do
actually what can you do
would anybody actually want to be black
here
that's logical right because black has
to create some sort of counter attack
and repeats with the attacking pawn um
rookie rook e8 would also be an
interesting choice to try to get rid of
the rooks
but
it's just so
uncomfortable i mean you have a
checkmate in one thread hahaha i'll just
move my king away and
i mean
i'm still
i'm still gonna come up here i'm still
gonna attack this or i'm still gonna
come up here it's like this or i'm gonna
come here attack this that's kind of why
we're talking about the dynamic elements
so
this won't happen this won't really work
with rook to ea durkee it won't really
solve any of black's problems so black
indie game renter
b8 attacking this little guy what do you
think we should do
we have multiple choices
i personally kind of like one of them a
little bit more than the others so
um
a7
you could take that
if you take that they'll take here
and you could try and eat over here and
now well you drop a little
so
let me rephrase that sorry
you can try and go after pawns but if
you do that your opponent starts to kind
of attack you a little too so i like
your idea i wanted to go after pawns but
you can't really save this guy unless
you play knight a2 which i don't really
want to
it just feels weird to
play knight to different one pawn so why
not b5 now that they take okay now take
back and nobody's attacking your knight
i know that we're not technically
winning upon in that situation but we
would still be keeping our momentum and
the opponent is still not attacking us
and we're still hoping to get active
still get still get active still attack
so i would prefer opponent to not have
an open file
like
if we took first
this situation i would have like is some
sort of attack right
and i don't want to spend another move
moving the night and they can attack
this guy again so you see it's kind of a
you want to take away that
potential for momentum away
all right so b5 take take now opponent
play b4
um where do you think is a good spot for
tonight
could be nice but knight e2 makes a lot
of sense as well because we want to be
able to block over here
no
so let's say that who are now rook c8
knowledge
what is a what is a potential problem
with your position
exactly fix it
yeah the reason behind f3 is both the
back rank and we want to include the
kink and we want to stop potential funny
stuff with their knight
so we're like
hitting multiple goals i was going to go
with hitting two birds with one stone
but i never understand the concept of
why would anybody want to hit birds with
stones so
so
yeah
so fix your background get your king in
the game and take away a bunch of their
squares
now they're offering a rook exchange yay
or nay
that's a name
i mean i think honestly either one is
fine but what is your personal
preference
one thing that i've noticed with a lot
of my students is that they are
so
not fan of end games
uh like specific end games like whenever
they want like there's exchange they
would if they're playing like if they're
playing for win they don't want to
exchange which is fair but if you trust
your
skill sets in end games then you don't
mind going to end game
so
kind of pros and cons here
you don't have to exchange your p7 is
totally fine too but if you are the type
of person who would take it
well
alejand made the same choice here
all right now what
thomas i'm
neglecting to ask but i think i have to
what time is it where you're at
all right
um
white tumor what do you think we should
do shall we just get the king involved
or can we try to do some funny business
with our bishop
i like bishop g club i don't think
there's anything specifically wrong with
it but if we do that then we are leaving
this poor guy behind
so it could be a new target
so why not just get the king out
i'm not entirely sure if i want to bring
the king all the way up here
but
i'm sorry i'm hearing some cool music
i can't figure out where is this coming
from not that i'm complaining
but if there's a nice jazz i feel like i
should be in the mood for it
all right
well
what now
oh
i would love to be able to eat this pond
can we make that happen
i am a little hungry not
kidding it's been a long day
patrick is saying looks like an easy win
get the king in now there's no might
that's fair pawns are weak also true
slow improvement white has one
additional piece
i mean technically you're right because
you have that additional piece it means
your pieces can work better together
also so let's see how can i make that
happen
i like that
they have to try and defend it now what
you're coming back here i'm sorry
oh i mean i think yeah bishop v3 is
totally fine i think bishop v3 is nice
even if knight c4 you can just bring the
bishop to d4 i'm totally fine with that
good job king e3 was played in a
specific game and just putting the king
in front of the pawn and activating the
king because in end games it's so
important to have your king active
because king is you know
usually if you're like oh kings you
gotta tuck them away but that's not
necessarily true when it comes to end
games and end games but we would want to
use our kings it's an it's a piece
that's going to take squares away from
opponent and it's going to attack around
now
there are some end games that you know
we would want to avoid that
but usually the way people think about
end game is like endgame is a phase of
the game that is kind of safe for your
king to join the party so
not necessarily true all the time
because i have gotten weird checkmates
in the endgame
but all right let's say black is still
trying to kick and fight and stuff what
do you do now
i mean i feel like
you have to move the knights and where
would you want to go
you definitely can i don't think there's
anything wrong with it but why not
knight h5 attack over here might want to
give check here
thank you patrick
there's an official request from patrick
for party king emote i'm not opposed to
it guess we'll get
i'll i've relayed the message we'll see
how that will turn out yeah that makes
sense and
black here just resigned because like
what what can they do like h6 will
awesome i'll just give a check you'll
move your king
and
i can't even develop and attack you if
you take awesome i'll just take this guy
too
and my two pieces and kink are just way
more active than your king and your rook
and i will be eating your palms to be
fair i don't think i mean yes white has
definitely advantage and white will most
likely win this game unless they blunder
but i would still kind of vote for
continuing a little bit more although to
be honest if i was playing the aldehyde
i probably would resign too
but this is a very very uncomfortable
game
and it all kind of started from
the first of all opening choice second
of all this really cool sacrifice idea
because you know people might think you
can't take it they'll eat your rook
right because this pawn is pinned but
that's not true you want to take it you
want to make sure this queen is moving
bunch of times keep in mind the queen
came to d5 early on then it went to a5
then it went to a1
then again after a few moves we attacked
it it had to go back
so it's a bunch of temples and that's
another reason why it's like the cliche
of don't bring your queen too early
it's
kind of true
it's again depending on the position
depending on the opening but for the
most part it is true because you if you
bring your queen out too early it's very
easily accessible and you whites develop
i mean opponent develop attack it queen
move again upon a develop attack it
so it would be um ideal to avoid that
from happening
all right
this game was
really awesome thank you for
staying around because we definitely
that did not set i did not see that
coming
anyways i'm going to jump into another
kind of cool game this is a game that's
uh geller played as white
against steen i'm probably
mispronouncing this so i apologize
uh it is it was played 1975.
um
again you should have access to this
study because i usually add all my
material to the same study until there's
no more room left and then i'll open a
new study
all right
um i'm gonna go a little faster through
the opening but we're still gonna talk
about it
first question that i have who here
plays
the maroxy bind
didn't start as marxi but it definitely
turned into it
anybody
play this as white or black
i'll give it a minute see how the chat
is feeling
well to be honest it did not have to
turn into demoroxy bind
usually the way i get myoxybind this
through this
uh maybe knight c6 first actually
this is usually how i get my my mark c
bind
but in this game
it happened this way
and it's still the same idea right
exactly it's also from sicilian yep
that's how i usually get my marxy bind
and some of the big ideas are first
things first
whenever black has control over the g4
square bishop e3's
uh you need to be prepared because if i
played bishop e3 now then knight g4 can
get a little yucky
so be careful with that
i'm very more i used to bishop g7s then
i bishop e3 yet i need d6 then i bishop
e2 to defend it kind of transposes but
still so you want to be careful about
your move order
and all right now question
is there anybody gonna long castle here
white or black
i agree it's highly unlikely
because either if either one of them do
long castle then it's just going to be
really weak
so no too long castle and i support that
suggestion
now let's say here um
what do you think is a good idea for
white we want a short castle that's fair
they want a short castle that's also
fair
but the thing is if we castle then they
castle and it's a little
too easy
i want to create troubles for my
opponent how can i create some potential
troubles for my opponents while you're
thinking about that i'll give you a
little bit of a
idea
um i don't remember which students
because man i've been teaching a lot
but recently i was um looking at one of
my students games and in this game my
opponent brought their bishop and pinned
their knight and i was like well i kind
of want to resolve that pin really
quickly i would really want to go like
punish x3 attack the g4 bishop and just
be like okay so what that bishop wants
to do either they want to take the
knight which is fine i'm prepared for
that this is good for me or they're
going to go back and keep the pin which
is also fine or they have to or they
have to you know stop the pin so the
fact that you would give your opponent
that choice sometimes kind of messes
with their head because it's is
um
sometimes they just mess up sometimes
they stop the pin sometimes they take
the night too early
or sometimes they
make weird blunders
so my point being a huge part of chess
is
not just about your good moves it's also
about giving your opponent the
opportunity to mess up
so keeping that in mind what do we do
well i have a thing in the chat somebody
wants to play pawn to g4
it looks fun but
man i don't have that big of a
courage
you could but that doesn't really
interfere with the
mistake abilities my thought is if you
go up here what if i just go even if i
just go upon i-6 you have to come back
and you lose a temple
even if you could eat here there's
always look at this type of checks
it doesn't the the move knight b5
doesn't really go with the rhythm of the
position
knight d5 looks kind of interesting but
again doesn't really go with the rhythm
of the position they're still going to
castle what about bishop g5
they should still castle
and if they castle now they might want
to move the knight somewhere well maybe
not d5 but somewhere
okay maybe not take here either but if
they move the knights then they're
attacking or queen right
so let's say they should have castled
and then if they do then probably moving
the queen away from this diagonal would
have been wise
but in the game bishop g5 black didn't
cast the black played bishop e6
attacking here
now what do you think we should do
i'll give you a hint
uh in this game black actually continued
to make little mistakes after mistakes
of not castling
which meant for us that we got the
chance to keep the king in the center
and attack it
so try to think of kind of attacking
moves
it doesn't have to be a crazy like i'm
going to go c5 if i have h4 not nothing
that's crazy you want to do call moves
developing moves
dude i just said no crazy moves i'm
getting a bunch of f4s and c5s and e5s
in the chat
ah knight d5 still look crazy
well castle is normal that's fair i
agree but
this is a weird thing to explain i feel
like if i castle then my opponent will
remember oh yeah i should castle too
i don't think that was the exact way
that geller was thinking about it
but
if i mean if opponent is not castling
and i don't have to cast them if i
castle then it feels like i'm being like
yeah yeah you should castle two this
reminds me um like in over the board
tournaments there's usually clock right
so like when you move make a move you
press the clock but sometimes i had
opponents who wouldn't press the clock
they would forget and usually i would
remind them hey you didn't press your
clock and then at some point i was like
wait why am i doing this
their time is running out
so if you cast them it kind of feels
like you're reminding your opponent yo
castle castle your press or clock
no no no don't be nice
all right so what now
okay i'm getting more like rook moves
okay rook d1 looks interesting what
about rook c1
because if you do castle then this trip
could be fun on d1
so rook c1 i'm kind of fond of it
again opponent should be castling but
opponent is not queen a5 they're
attacking my bishop what should i do
now we can't really cast though
f4 still fails
still well what if they take it though
i don't wanna i don't want my opponent
to be happy
uh the suggestion is f4 is also
interesting but what if they go h6
why not okay this is seems to be a
problem this diagonal just move your
queen away from it defend this
you might have some potential my d5
ideas later on because then their queen
would be
loose
so could be nice to do knight d5
here again they should be castling but
they're not they play rook c8s seems
like they want to eat your pawn
now what
but we're already defending this guy
you're good
i'm getting a bunch of b trees in the
chat i'm getting a few castles i'm
getting a b4 oh mama
yeah
95 is an idea but think of it this way
if they've already taken here
and then you do knight d5 this bishop is
kind of pinned right
so that could be like a sneak attack
that you can do to the opponent
so they're te i mean they are
threatening this but i don't believe
this is a strong attack so can we just
kind of let them attack it for no reason
i think castle here is interesting but
the problem with castle is take
now if you go knight d5 then they could
exchange it
and then this could fall
so how can you improve your knight d5
idea
and kind of not let this happen
so you are laying a trap with if take
knight d5 but if you go knight e5 then
nobody is defending this guy
so
[Music]
yeah
i feel like whenever i touch the f pawn
most of my students go
f3 f4 what
and that's true for the most part but i
haven't castle yet so i mean touching f3
it doesn't really weaken my king if i
don't intend to castle
just yet also if you're planning on
doing stuff in this diagonal i can
easily come back so f3 is you know has
pros and cons but the pros outweigh the
cons in this situation you do have to be
very careful when touching your f-pawn
but it's not always a no-no so all right
opponents here kind of made a amazing
move of take
all right now what to do we've already
talked about it so i'm assuming
uh should be fun what do you think we
should do now
yep 95 is a very common movie mario see
if they take they're pretty toast you
take back with the bishop this guy is
pinned
uh they can't really i mean they could
defend it i guess but they'll lose it
sooner or later
um
so 95 is indeed a very common move in
morocci and i've also seen quite a lot
of it's in dragon here and there
but the the point being that opponents
made a mistake the opponent's biggest
mistake was not castling just because
i'm not casting doesn't mean you
shouldn't
i'm gonna castle now i do
and i think it's kind of funny because
castling here was
definitely not the best move
uh surprisingly knight b4 is the best
one but it's a little bit of an engine
move because queen let's take one goes
to a4
then you take over here then they can
castle
wait why is this engine move let's just
go here what am i missing
oh yes that's what i was missing e5
yeah
but it is it is a little bit of an
engine move so i can understand why this
was not really
the fan favorite
because you know knight b4 just feels
like um coin b3 and i
you have to find e4 and e4 e5
if you don't you can't really just take
it they'll just take back and they're
gonna have advantage you could castle
but then they can just start attacking
you around here
so you have to find e5
and e5 is definitely a bit of an engine
move so castling is completely
comfortable
now opponent took knight takes d5
and what do you think we should do now
to be fair it takes d5 is fine not two
but if you do that then you're not
attacking much so black can just castle
so what do you think we should do
hi tracy
ah queen taste d5 what
b3 dude they just ate my piece
either gotta eat this or gotta eat this
your choices are very limited
yeah take the rook take the bishop with
the rook if you take they can castle i
don't like that
so we have to take over here
if they take now what here was the true
intermezzo
what do we do now
how can we
kind of punish opponents for their loose
pieces
for their
centralized well
stuck in the center king
all right
wait what
why pawn
if you take with queen you're pinning
right and you're attacking again yeah
exactly
uh in the game rookie four happened
and can you think of a good response to
rook a4
here actually
white has clear advantage but rk4 just
made things much easier
i like it thank you
now what
kind of a funny move right now
to be honest taking is also
doable but you definitely lessen your
advantage
if not to lose it completely
so what else
you also don't want to exchange queens
so let me let me ask you a different way
what is a big problem that black has
hold on what's the
no queen thanks b7 what if they still
give check
and then they just run up with the king
the big problem opponent has their king
right
they would want to put it in safety but
they can't what is the one piece that
you have not
activated yet
uh-huh yeah perk c1 just go for the
checkmate threads
if they give check that's awesome
because you can take it and if they take
back you can check over here and kaboom
but if they i mean if they give the
check you'll take it but i'm assuming
they won't
i'm kind of hoping that they resign here
which they kind of did actually
um but i you know like this game by no
means was a lost cause like a few moves
ago all black had to do was just castle
so
know your openings
keep your kings safe
keep your pieces uh peace activities
to a very very annoying level
and they'll be nice to your opponents i
think those are good advice for tuesday
i
yes i will see everybody
uh tomorrow
on
twitch
from two to four come play me from 6 30
to 8 30
come watch me
yeah
all right with that uh feel free to
congratulate me in the comments for my
mizzou med school acceptance
and
stuff like that
and thank you everybody for being here
today i will see you tomorrow
[Music]
you